the best way to learn a language it
turns out is not to sit in a class and
recite the different verbs and nouns
a lot of research and a lot of anecdotal
evidence tells us that the best way to
learn a language
is through immersion it's to live in
another country speak and hear
only that language and let the amazing
plasticity of our brain
do its thing training is no different
we are adaptoids our bodies are designed
to adapt to our surroundings
and this is the key to unlocking perfect
performance this might sound like a
pleasant platitude
but in fact i believe it's also
supported by ever increasing evidence
let's see a few of the ways in which
lifestyle trumps training
firstly no stimulus will ever be as
profound as the environment
best case scenario you might work out
for an hour or two a day
this is nothing compared to the amount
of time many of us spend sitting in our
seats and typing
or lying on the safe for watching tv
that's the main stimulus
it should come as no surprise then that
we experience tight hip flexors
rounded shoulders and beer bellies as
i've often explained
this is not maladaptive this is
functional for the lifestyles that we
lead
this also goes some way to explaining
the seemingly inexplicable farmer
strength
they don't train to failure but they
train all day
training with huge volume will always
generate huge results
so long as the recovery is equal to the
energy expended and overload is cautious
and progressive
i think high rep calisthenics are the
perfect example of this
recently i've been championing the use
of high rep calisthenics with a
continuous time under tension
this type of training has the ability to
flood the working muscles of blood
reducing venous return as well as
maximally fatiguing all the muscle
fibers
it can permanently increase blood supply
to those muscles by capillarization
which additionally increases my nuclei
for permanently improved hypertrophy
it builds strength endurance the most
useful type of strength that allows us
to exert power for long durations
without fatiguing and failing
this is also highly protective against
injury the problem
huge repetitions of moderately
challenging movements take time
and don't fit neatly into a given
training program they work best when
spread throughout the day
like so many accounts of prisoners and
legendary old-time strongmen
the same goes for like cardio spread
throughout the day this goes a long way
to explaining the seemingly superhuman
feats of indigenous peoples
such as the tarahumara known for running
marathon-like distances
every single day but it's not just the
body that benefits from this kind of
total immersion
the brain also helps refine and improve
movement through continuous
distributed repetition this is greasing
the groove
as described by pavel tatsulin this
means repeating a movement
intermittently throughout the day
so as to reinforce neural pathways
for example you might perform a pull-up
every time you pass through a doorway
or you might practice a turkish get-up
every morning and night
strength is a skill says pavel instead
of focusing on muscle damage and
metabolic stress
instead focus on repetition so that you
develop the most flawless technique
that way you recruit only the necessary
muscle fibers with no wasted energy
you become stronger without the fatigue
training in this way has other benefits
too
this allows us to tap into something
called space repetition or distributed
practice
research shows us that when you spread
any form of learning throughout the day
you actually see more rapid learning and
better retention
this makes sense as each new session
requires you to perform the movement
from cold as it were coincidentally this
is also how you would use the movement
in real life
we don't get a nice little rehearsal
period first
not only that but each learning session
is followed by a cooldown period
during which you will experience post
activation potentiation in the relevant
neural pathways
as well as the short term plasticity we
discussed recently
in other words your brain doesn't just
reset more separate cooldowns
means more total activation
each new learning session will spike
chemicals like brain-derived
neurotrophic factor
and in the case of resistance training
it might also spike protein synthesis
growth hormone testosterone and more
you'll raise your metabolism repeatedly
too
then there's the simple fact that any
block of training will likely lead to
some fatigue
and loss of focus
strategically breaking your training up
means introducing more rest time
allowing you to start each new block
fresh and with mental clarity
what do you do during these rests though
you continue to learn in other ways
you continue to try other types of
movement you intersperse your training
with other activities
this introduces the interference effect
and research shows that when you mix up
drills rather than performing blocks of
the same type of training
you actually see a drop in performance
during those training sessions
but greater performance and retention
host training
in real life we're rarely required to
repeat a single movement over and over
without varying so why would we stand in
the corner of our gym
curling on the spot
likewise we should avoid repeating
movements exactly all together
to learn the perfect deadlift you must
practice the perfect deadlift over and
over
you must ensure that the movement is as
identical as possible
each and every time this is useful for
competition
but it's not that useful in real life or
in sports
there are no straight bars in real life
there are few flat surfaces
rarely do we have the luxury of perfect
form if you're wrestling climbing or
moving furniture
you'll need to lift from awkward angles
with varied momentum
it is by introducing variety and
confounding variables into training that
we therefore become more
ready for anything this way we develop
what nikolai bernstein refers to as
more robust neural maps movement
patterns emerge from constraints
organism environment and goal this is
dynamical systems theory
as applied to motor learning
imbalances and overuse injuries are
rarely the result of using muscles too
often
rather they are the result of using
particular movement patterns at the
exclusion
of all others tennis elbow doesn't occur
because those movements are harmful
it occurs very often because the muscles
of the forearm aren't being equally
trained
gyphosis occurs because the front is
stronger and tighter than the back and
it band pain often afflicts runners
because they rarely move in the frontal
plane and wear thick supporting shoes
movement is medicine but only if it's
sufficiently varied and balanced
just like nutrition continuous movement
can even help to encourage recovery
if you stop moving a joint to protect it
you give the body no incentive
to heal the affected area you develop
awkward compensatory movement patterns
that worsen the problem and you actively
prevent blood flow
growth hormone and protein synthesis in
the affected area
this can even go so fast to accelerate
aging a single setback often coalesces
into a multitude of problems
that become too entangled to unravel
did you know that one of the best ways
to encourage rapid recovery and growth
post training is to use light jogging
or even a very light recovery set for
the muscles you trained in the previous
workout
the same thing applies to injuries on a
grander scale
and on a similar note blood flow
restriction training can also help to
accelerate recovery
too many functional trainers will take a
reductionist approach to solving this
problem
they will write training programs that
they hope will offer perfect balance
make sure you're training external
rotation for those rotator cuffs
make sure you're strengthening the
erector spinae the body is far too
complex for us to write a training
program that strengthens every single
muscle
and every single movement in perfect
balance the only solution there is to
subject ourselves to the kinds of
environments
that challenge us and are just as
complex and chaotic as we are
then we let our bodies do their thing do
what they were designed to do the same
goes for cognitive function by the way
we maintain brain plasticity and healthy
connectivity by challenging ourselves in
varied and ever-changing ways
novel experiences bring our brains to
life and keep them young
nutrition is equally as complicated
there are millions of supplements that
claim to make you super healthy
a million ingredients that do us harm
and no one can agree on which of which
only by eating a highly varied natural
and unprocessed diet
can we be confident that we're getting
what we need
so what we're looking at here is a light
highly varied non-taxing training
naturally mixed up throughout the day no
gym session can achieve this
but our environment achieves it
naturally you will adapt
and of course this also helps us to
become physically stronger by developing
the supporting muscles that are so often
overlooked
the organisms that survive and thrive
are those that can adapt to their
surroundings
this happens on a grand scale over the
course of millions of years through
evolution
but also within a single lifetime the
problem is that humans
more so than any other creature we know
of have the uncanny ability to shape
their environment and what we aim to do
with this ability
to make everything as comfortable and
safe as possible everything is soft and
warm and easy
the extent of this is easy to miss
because we're so accustomed to it
but even our cupboards and shelves exist
only to make things easier for us
to the extent we never even have to bend
over or reach up high
everything's at arm height
my book functional training and beyond i
discussed the possibility of a space
specifically designed
to change our bodies for the better i
called it the adaptation facilitation
machine
and the aim was to design a building
that would make the resident stronger
smarter and healthier
simply by virtue of existing there
imagine a hallway with a balance beam
imagine if you had to push heavy doors
open every time you move to another room
imagine a climbing wall instead of
stairs
imagine if you had to crank a stiff
handle to get water from a tap
maybe your dishwasher would require you
to answer some simple sums before it
started
all these changes could ensure we keep
moving throughout the day and stay
strong
mobile and alert of course to truly
prevent desensitization
the ultimate adaptation facilitation
machine would also need to reconfigure
itself
to provide a variety and to maintain an
appropriate level of challenge
i know it's a goofy concept but i'd love
to see this idea take shape in the way
we design our homes
and the way we consider living spaces
especially for the less mobile
maybe we need to reconsider the idea of
making everything as easy as possible
all the time
and to be clear this essay is not
arguing that we should go back to the
wild for optimum health
in fact using the knowledge we now have
i wonder if we couldn't create a
superior environment to shape our bodies
for the rest of us in the meantime we
can incorporate these ideas in other
ways
by training outdoors and in the elements
by going barefoot and rounding off the
beaten path
by training with a variety of styles and
tools and by making more effort to train
throughout the day
not just during set workouts
we achieved this then by changing our
relationship with the environment
because as in dynamical systems theory
your intent and also the habits and your
behaviors
alter the impact of the environment you
can choose to take two steps at a time
you can choose to jog rock farmers walk
or crawl to the shops
you can choose to squat while you watch
tv it's harder
but it's just as effective i call this
adaptive
immersion training and the simple
formula looks like this
adaptation equals environment times
organism times intent
all multiplied by plasticity
change the environment change the
organism
so i hope you found this one useful and
interesting guys it's some high concept
stuff but i feel it could be useful for
some people
let me know if you train like this how
does your environment shape your body
and performance
if you did enjoy this then please
consider leaving a like and sharing it
around
that helps me out immensely you could
also subscribe and hit the bell button
to ensure you're notified of new uploads
and some awesome news i think we've now
just crossed 400 000 subscribers which
is
insane so thank you all so much for that
and i thought a cool way to mark the
occasion might be with a q a it's
something people have asked me to do in
the past so
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask you can ask them in the comments
down below
on instagram i'll be posting about it or
on the facebook page
you'll find everything you need to know
in the description if you like this kind
of training that looks at the body and
the mind and
all different aspects of performance
then you might enjoy my ebook and
training program
super functional training there's a
discount on right now during the
pandemic
and you can find the link to that in
description down below also
or if you want to know where a lot of
this stuff came from then check out my
print book functional training
and beyond that i discuss functional
training as a concept
and how we can apply it to our training
and our general lives
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys thanks for all
your support
and i'll see you next time bye
for now